après les éprouvantes dépositions des
experts et notamment du médecin légiste
l'employeur de la victime est une proche
de la famille fouillot se sont exprimés
à la barre
s'attachant à décrire les qualités
d'alexia d'aval elle exactement ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure
gentil pétillant gay mais la vie à une
femme dominatrice à une castratrice pas
unis une personnalité écrasante comme je
lui ai entendu quelques françaises et du
viennent parler d'alexia ce soir j'ai lu
tellement dur à supporter un procès je
savais pas que c'était aussi intense et
cette journée était aussi très très
compliqué avec les légistes des choses
donc un peu de douceur ce soir ça va ce
petit bleu ce soir ce mercredi les
parties civiles et notamment les parents
d'alexia pourront prendre la parole à
leur tour la cour entendra ensuite
l'accusé lui-même johnattan d'abba